good evening thanks for joining us here
at 11 i'm denise valdez
as our country continues fighting the
rise in coronavirus cases the flu
poses another risk to people and to our
health care system
here in the valley flu season has made
an impact usually pretty
early in years past but take a look at
this this time actually last year
the health district had already reported
three flu
deaths and more than a hundred patients
had been hospitalized because of the flu
but this year a lot different all the
way through the start of november there
have been no hospitalizations and no
deaths
that's due in part to more people
wearing masks sanitizing their hands
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough is
live tonight with more on how this flu
season could be different
in light of the coronavirus madison yes
that's right so we currently are
in flu season but with covet 19 taking
center stage
that could mean a variety of different
things for you when you're trying to
keep safe
the symptoms of the flu and the symptoms
of covid19 overlap more than they are
distinct
the only two main differences there seem
to be with contracting covid
is that many people seem to lose their
sense of taste and smell
also the rate at which one feels
symptoms covid typically takes three to
seven days
before you start feeling symptoms flu
you can
you'll feel the symptoms a lot quicker
typically
they are both respiratory viruses and
for months now the cdc has been telling
us that the best way to combat the
covid19 virus
is to wear a mask wash your hands for 20
seconds
keep your distance from others and avoid
physical contact
those tips are crucial for keeping us
safe from the flu as well
the good thing is that the way that you
avoid one
is the way you avoid both and if you
wonder if masks and other precautions
work
well they're likely the reason why we're
seeing better numbers this year when it
comes to the flu
because people have been
utilizing their covid precautions we are
seeing
far less flu than we saw in 2019-2020
as of october 31 2020 no one had died or
even was hospitalized with the flu
in clark county now compare that to the
same time last year
and there were 102 people hospitalized
and three deaths
so why are covet 19 cases soaring and
not the flu
there's no concrete answer but one
possible reason is the flu vaccine
every year people get their flu shot but
of course as of now there's no vaccine
for coronavirus
so could getting the flu vaccine help
fight covid19
it's still unknown but the chances of it
helping are greater than being treated
with nothing
now as for the flu shot the doctor did
tell me that one in six nevadans
do get it but that is far behind the
rest of the country denise
so madison you pointed out in your story
that you can get either virus the same
way
is it possible to get covid and the flu
at the same time
yeah so you could potentially get it at
the same time but that's why it's so
important to get the vaccine to help
all right madison kimbrough reporting
live tonight appreciate it